hey guys it's max and vadim and today
we're taking a look at the new galaxy s
20 alt rrah and we're gonna be doing a
camera comparison and not like the
typical ones that you guys might have
already seen but this is gonna be a
blind style so vadim hasn't seen these
images here and he's gonna be looking at
him and choosing which one he likes
better and why you guys can join in as
well get a piece of paper ready and
after each photo we're just gonna put in
tally marks which one he liked to see at
the end you know how these actually
compare in the real world unbiased and
let me tell you guys this is Pi has this
video buddy has the biggest swing in
terms of one camera doing better in
certain scenarios another camera doing
better in other scenarios that I've seen
from all the camera tests we've done in
the last you know two three years so
it's gonna get very interesting let's go
ahead and jump in I'll give you guys
couple pointers as we go to where we're
gonna get some interesting results so
here's the first image as a selfie
anxiety let's see so the one on the
right I don't know why it's looks so
like flat and kind of blueish one of the
Middle's a little bit dim I would
honestly go with the one on the left
because the dynamic range that I think
is a little bit better yeah it's a
little bit too warm but I would still go
with this one for sure I agree and I
don't even remember which one is which
s1 tally mark so this one is a crop into
an ultra white so we can look at detail
that's why I only have two here because
the pixel does not have ultra wide lens
so just looking at it right now there's
definitely more detail on the one on the
Left you're right that one definitely
has more detail and here are the full
shots which one do you like better out
of the two I'm still going with the one
on the left it's a little bit brighter I
think I like that alright
that is the s20 ultra now this is a
macro photo taken with the main lens and
these shots are really tricky because of
focusing so I took multiple shots with
each one and I picked out the best one
alright so I can see that the one on the
right there's a lot more blur and it's
almost distracting it's almost too much
and it's got this blue tint that I don't
really like it's not variables
one of the Middle's really balanced but
I really I like the pop of the color on
the one on the left so I'm going with
that one okay 11 row I would disagree I
would choose the pixel but no problem
this is a high to voting and this test
right here is flaring so I'm shooting
right into the Sun and we're testing how
well these lenses can resist flaring
hands-down the one in the middle that's
easy
absolutely I absolutely agree that is
the s20 ultra great job and the iPhone
looks probably the worst a few degree
it's horrendous horrendous and this is a
shot using the portrait lens and this is
a regular object here it's not a person
this is very difficult so I was focusing
on the lanterns which one do you like so
I think the one on the right because
they light inside of the lanterns is
blown out on the one in the center and
the one on the left that's actually not
bad this was actually pretty good too
but I think the one on the right is the
closest to the actual color it was
pixels floor I was surprised it
definitely looks better in this shot I
was trying to take a wide portrait shot
of the running man getting him
completely in the frame the pixel is
actually in the center here and it crops
on automatically in portrait mode it
doesn't give you the option to take a
white shot so which one do you like
better out of these two I think I like
the one on the right I like the extra
contrast I like the the look of the
asphalt looks more natural I guess
compared to the other one so the one on
the right oh that's 20 ultra and this
shot right here is meant to look at
colors we have a lot of cloud colors on
these blocks right here obviously we
have sky the dirt there which one is
more pleasing color wise I think I'd go
with the one on the left
I mean the the colors pop a lot more
it's really balanced I think it looks
more sharp as well okay yes 20 ultra
what's like your Samsung man
and this one is extremely difficult this
is during sunrise it's super bright
outside kind of darker inside the house
a real estate type shot I definitely
don't like the one in the center it's
between the one on the left and right
and I think the one on the right has too
much contrast it's a little bit too dark
and
I like the overall balanced look of the
one on the left so it's that one he
takes so for this is cropped in about
500% from that previous image and I did
mix them up which one looks better so
the one on the right looks a little bit
blurry you don't get that much detail it
looks like the one on the center has a
ton of sharpening and contrast at it to
try to make I guess more detail so I'd
honestly go with the one on the left
that is the iPhone so last second point
is iPhone and for this one I actually
zoomed into the photo because we have a
48 megapixel 4x optical zoom with their
fancy AI over sampling all these
techniques so I believe this is roughly
8 X zoom or so even though I like the
balance and colors better on the one in
the center I definitely see a lot more
detail on the one on the left with these
little plants flowers or whatever and
especially this ring around the clock
it's super sharp so definitely that one
s 2000 and now we have an ultra wide
photo here once again the pixels in the
middle it can't do alt right
unfortunately which one out of these two
looks better okay so I think the one on
the right because I could definitely see
a lot more detail in the waves in the
water
definitely more detail there and I think
in the building trees s20 ultra again
good job samsung here we have a portrait
mode shot and one of them the one on the
left actually wasn't able to do portrait
mode at that distance where the two on
the right we're able to but we have a
much different result so I like the
extra blur the one on the center but I
do see some issues I see that this
little duck head way back there is not
blurred out at all so it's kind of this
weird little glitch so it looks
unnatural for that to happen and I do
see that unlike the one on the left you
do get a little bit of blur in the
background so it looks like this might
actually be like what a pro camera would
do from this distance it wouldn't have
this much blur 11/0 and pro okay here's
another really difficult situation in
terms of dynamic range so what I'm
seeing here is there's definitely a lot
more detail right there in that dirt
it's blown out on both
left on the right camera so you're
getting that extra detail and the the
darks the shadows are also nicely
exposed more detail right here in these
bricks compared to the other two so
definitely the one in the middle
s2000 truck recipe and I will say that
this is the only one that got the white
balance correct as well and here I have
a portrait shot with the front facing
the s20 ultra has a 40 megapixel front
facing camera whereas the pixel has an 8
megapixel and the iPhone has a 12 I'm
gonna go with the one on the right
because there's quite a bit of shadows
like right above your eyes right there
and this one looks the most natural I
guess this is the one I would choose
personally that one is the iPhones and
now it's time to go back to that zoom
lens and here I have a scenario where I
was standing quite far back and this is
roughly 15 X zoom so I did actually crop
in on the two other cameras to match it
up alright so the one on the Left I see
a lot of noise and blotchiness in the
sky or like all over it the one on the
right you get a little bit of noise not
very noticeable a little bit more detail
for sure but the one in the center this
just destroys it looks the sky little
smooth that everything's incredibly
detailed you could see the texture I'm
really surprised that this was from the
sample now will not suppress from
sampling I'm surprised by how well this
shot turned out and now we have a
hundred times zoom so I already have the
results here obviously yeah this is what
the the s20 looks like it looks terrible
I wouldn't want this photo on my phone
but obviously it looks at that it does
the best then digitally cropping another
two and here we have a macro shot using
the telephoto lenses and once again I
shot around five or six shots and chose
the best one cuz macro shots are so
difficult and I got as close as I could
with the lenses and then to maintain a
sharp image so for some reason the one
on the left is pretty far back so I
guess it couldn't focus closely in
between the other two it's really close
but I think I like the one on the right
for the extra pop of color especially in
those little flower buds or whatever
that is so the one on the right I think
the one on the right is the iPhone 11
and pro so this is interesting you guys
see that the s20 ultra can't focus that
closely that's the close I could get
because the lens is using that mirror
design the sensor is sideways you need
to be a lot further for it to properly
focus now you could do more digital zoom
in this image but that is a limitation
you guys should know about now in this
image I cropped in extra in post but it
was originally shot using two times zoom
and I want to see what the detail looks
like if we want that zoom amount right
so I think I'm seeing more detail on the
one on the right especially in those
little feathers right there I think I do
it might just be contrast but honestly I
like the one on the right the most and
here's that same image just the normal
shot this was two times do you change
your mind at all or sticking with the
same result I like how bright this one
is but it's honestly a little bit blown
out in certain areas I think I'm still
gonna go with the one on the right that
is the s20 ultra this is another thing I
wanted to make you guys aware of if
you're using the two times zoom with s20
ultra it actually is using the one time
zoom and cropping in twice digitally
from that 108 megapixels so it still
does a good job even though you're
cropping in on the sensor whereas the
other two actually have lenses for that
now this is another ultra wide shot so
we have only the Samsung and the iPhone
and here I wanted to look at dynamic
range this is super dark underneath this
bridge super bright outside what does it
look like to you so I'm seeing more
dynamic range particularly in the sky
you get a lot more cloud detail and
right here underneath you get more
detail whereas this is a little bit
blown out and also I think the shadows
are brought up more so it's a more
balanced image and you could do more
with this one so the one on the right 11
Pro pro not a massive difference but it
definitely the iPhones ultra lights a
little bit better at dynamic range and
here we have another portrait mode shot
this guy was wondering what I was doing
out in downtown and he asked me to take
some photos so we have portrait shots
here I think the one on the left is a
little bit too warm and the his face is
like really flat there's not much I
guess change in skin too
or anything in his face and the one in
the center is a little bit over contrast
II maybe it's definitely nice and sharp
especially on his jacket but I think I
would prefer the one on the right
s2000 ultra okay you're a Samsung man
all right and here we have a portrait
shot except for we are inside we have a
studio light for that kind of effect on
your face with the shadow drop off and
some bokeh balls so looking at these I
can tell that a lot of the color is gone
on the one in the center just my face
looks like really white almost like a
little bit blown out and between the one
on the left and the right I'm seeing a
lot of sharpening and contrast on the
left and like my hair is like really
black and I think the one on the right
looks the most natural it's more
balanced I think I would choose with
that one okay that is that price phone
and I would choose the pixel how to say
that yeah I thought the pixel kept the
shadows nicely let's go to the next one
this is interesting what the heck what
in the world
so we reshot this multiple times to make
sure it wasn't a fluke I looked at other
areas and one of these phones clearly
could not handle that lamp and ibadah
needed to make it the white balance auto
white balance thought it needed to in
the world makes it where's the other two
we're able to handle the situation's
horrible so between these two I'm seeing
like softening in my face like I don't
really see my texture come here to the
left I see like some skin texture and
different stuff like that I'm seeing
more texture in my shirt as well so I
think I'm gonna go with the left one the
iPhone one and this is a situation where
a deep fusion will kick in and that is
why you're seeing those differences and
the pixel I don't know this is another
shot in kind of medium lighting using
that standard lens alright so the white
balance is destroyed on the left that's
probably the pixel for again because
it's so blue in between the the center
and the right I'm seeing a lot more
detail in the texture of the panel
I can more easily read the text on the
YouTube plaque and like this lens right
here I'm honestly liking the center for
sure that one is the 11pro now this test
was set up and I wasn't expecting this
result to test out the hundred eight
megapixels compared to deep fusion so in
that medium lighting 12 megapixels but
using you know computer AI whatever
algorithm stuff stacking images it
actually beat out as far as detail and
having a hundred eight megapixel so that
was very interesting and I was not
expecting that result and here is that
same image but right now I used the
telephoto lenses to see how they compare
yep Center again for sure and I like a
lot more detail rewrite there and this
is way too blue so Center and this one
wasn't mixed up I thought just to show
you guys the difference and this
scenario was set up and it wasn't
cherry-picked anything like that to test
out the extra lens the telephoto lens on
here compared to the telephoto lenses on
the other ones 48 megapixel but the
downside to having this you know way
bigger way more magnification basically
is that it's an F 3.7 lens I believed
okay and we'll put it but the lens line
the lens ones up here for you guys to
see that means there's a lot less light
coming in and even though we have more
megapixels because we have less light
the image turns out less detailed and
this shot right here is using the 2x
zoom option so the s20 doesn't have the
chance to use the telephones in this
scenario and this is a brighter sort of
lighting but not ultra bright alright so
the one in the center just my skin looks
really pale so definitely not that one
between the left and the right they both
do a pretty good job I think I think I
see more detail on the one on the left
but I like how the one on the right is
able to keep that light bulb less blown
out and have more color on my shirt and
my pants and everything else so the one
on the right the s20 has less detail
because it has to crop into the sensor
even though it has 180 megapixels it is
edited
and now let's get into the really low
light situations this is using the front
camera using the night mode and one of
them obviously does not support night
mode for the front facing camera yeah so
the left one does not support that the
one in the center is definitely the
clear winner the one on the right is
just a little bit blurry some motion
blur going on so and it's focused on the
background yeah yeah pixel for it did it
doesn't look amazing
but it smokes the iPhone it sucks iPhone
doesn't have that option and it did
better than the s20 ultra and I will say
actually took pixel where I only took
one image the s20 ultra I took a couple
because it kept focusing on the
background if you can see that dangerous
and that's the issue that kept coming up
now we have another one this is medium
kind of lighting we have this field here
and this was handheld using about a five
second shutter or so alright so I could
see a lot more detail on the one on the
left and the colors look better as well
I see like in all this grass or whatever
tons of detail whereas this is all just
pasty and blotchy so left for sure
pixels for good job Google they're good
at their night modes get definitely a
clear winner and this shot was in
complete darkness so to my eyes I really
couldn't see anything and this was on
the tripod I will say that too so the
one on the left is just extremely flat
it's got like this weird tint to it
between the center and the right it's a
really tough call the one on the right
looks really blue and I don't know if it
was that blue it was completely black
I'll just say that everything was
completely bright so I think I'm gonna
go with the one in the center I feel
like the colors are probably more choice
to what it was yeah yeah if you figure
that image but just bright is probably
what you would see 11 Pro and a pixel 4
so the pixel 4 if you guys notice from
previous images they it likes to add
kind of a bluer sky which I personally
like how that looks
there's also another difference the
pixel for this was a 4 minute exposure 4
minute when it knows that you're on a
tripod it does a 4 minute and if you
blow this up more so it does have more
detail a little more sharpness where's
the s20 this was the best shot and other
ones were worse and really pasty and
flat and also the haloing around and I
don't know if that's just having you
take that 108 megapixels and not only
take all these shots and stack them
together with long exposure but we have
all the sampling that has to happen as
well so that was very interesting with
the 11pro this is a running shot and I
cropped in a little bit as well
every shot is actually InFocus I assumed
in I looked at him it tracked you very
very well the pixel for I think every
shot but one one was slightly out of
focus and then it tracked you very well
as well and I was looking at the
background to see if the focus was
changing whereas with the Samsung it
starts out with everything in focus
yeah very blue but then this is already
slightly out of focus especially on the
6k XDR out of focus
oh wow how to focus out of things
interesting and the reason why I want to
show this is I think Samsung has more
work to do as far as software they said
they're gonna work on focusing issues as
well but consistently shooting these
different images sometimes I'd have to
reshoot in this comparison because some
of the shots were just out of focus and
then I have one more shot here I think
you already know what's going on right
here this is a shot that I took
personally of a different object and
just noticed an issue trying to take a
close-up shot with the lens so here we
have three images which one looks better
today so we'll do it that way first it's
pretty close but I think the one on the
right because I'm seeing some kind of
blurriness over here at the top and
without entrepreneurs I think this one's
overall the best on the right yep and
then this one is the iPhone 11 Pro for
the pixel 4 in the s20 ultra and this is
something I just bugged me days they you
know shooting with this because the
sensor is quite a bit larger in this
camera it needs a larger lens and that's
why the camera bump is so much larger
but in fact in reality if this was a pro
camera the lens would be two three times
larger to be able to give enough quality
for a for the sensor and what happens is
when you try to do a close-up for a far
distance it's okay of focusing close up
the center is sharp but everything
really really blurs out where's the the
pixel has a little bit blurring not much
the iPhone does a really good job here
so I think that is it as far as the
testing
let's see what we got as far as our
results all right so we got 12 for the
s20 ultra we have 13 for the iPhone 11
Pro and forward for the pixel 4 oh man
that was pretty close oh yeah so I guess
I'll say overall I was really happy with
some of those as 20 shots especially
yeah when you're shooting outside with
either the main lens at 1x or that
telephoto at around from 4 to 10 it
looks really really good dynamic range
contrast they did a great job but in
some of these other situations that's
where the iPhones started to beat it out
because it's just it's better software
and more optimized so be interesting to
see what happens longer term after we
have some software improvements so there
you guys go let us know down in the
comments section below which one you
thought was better or what your score
was if you guys did this test as well
and if you want to see a comparison
between these two let us know as well I
will be doing a one-week switchover IREX
which for a couple days already so I'll
be doing a video letting you guys know
all the pros which there definitely are
some good pros and some cons switching
from my iphone to this new s20 ultra so
make sure you guys have that subscribe
button enable of the notifications also
enable down below and if you guys want
to see a couple other great videos we
have them right over there there's Ben
Max and Vadim and we'll see you in the
next one
[Music]